,
LIBERTY & LEVIN."
[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS'
WORLD," I'M JESSE WATTERS.
CRACKING THE CODE, THERE IS
SOMETHING MISSING, AMERICA.
BESIDES MY BOOK ON THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" BEST SELLER LIST.
THE MEDIA MOB FIX EIGHT ON
FLORIDA AND COVID.
WHAT CHANGED?
FLORIDA CASES WENT WAY DOWN.
THEY KICKED THEIR SUMMER SURGE.
EXTRA EXTRA READ ALL ABOUT IT.
BUT THE NATIONAL NEWS WON'T RUN
IT.
THE MEDIA MEMBER WHO WON'T TELL
YOU THE REST OF THE FLORIDA
STORY BECAUSE IT HAD A HAPPY
ENDING.
IF THE PLOT LINE CHANGES AND
GOES AGAINST THE NARRATIVE, THE
PRESS SKIPS TO THE NEXT ACT.
IF YOU ARE UNMASKED OR UNVAXXED,
YOU ARE A DEADLY WEAPON.
>> CHILDREN ARE NOT JUST
SUFFERING AND DYING AT GREATER
RATES, THEY ARE SPREADING COVID
THROUGH THE POPULATION AT HIGHER
NUMBERS.
PEOPLE DO NOT GET TO WALK AROUND
SHOOTING LOADED FIREARMS
RANDOMLY INTO CROWDS.
AND PEOPLE ARE NOT ENTITLED TO
TURN THEMSELVES INTO DEADLY
WEAPONS RANDOMLY KILLING
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
JESSE: IF YOU DON'T PLAY BY THE
LEFT'S RULES, YOU WILL BE DEEMED
A HEALTH THREAT, YOU ARE A BIO
WEAPON.
YOU ARE AN AR-COVID-19.
THE GOVERNMENT USED COVID-19 TO
STRIP YOU OF YOUR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT, FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AND RIGHT OF ASSOCIATION.
VOTING WAS ALTERED.
PRISONS EMPTIED.
THESE EMERGENCY POWERED
FUNDAMENTALLY QUHAINGD AMERICA.
A VIRUS SO THREATENING THE
SURVIVAL RATE WAS 99%.
NOW THAT WE HAVE THE VACCINE THE
THREAT IS DONE BUT THE IMAGINE
POWERS LINGER.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THIS.
>> WE ARE TAKING STEPS TO CON
FRONT NOT JUST THE GUN --
CONFRONT NOT JUST THE GUNNY IS
BUT WHAT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
>> THIS IS CLEARLY ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS, ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
THAT'S HARMING AMERICA'S HEALTH,
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE ABOUT
THIS.
JESSE: THE CDC IS TRACKING
AMERICANS COMING INTO E.R.s
WITH SURVIVABLE GUNSHOT WOUNDS.
AND IF HISTORY IS A GUIDE, THEY
WILL DEEM IT A HEALTH THREAT AND
LIMIT YOUR SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
THE PROPAGANDA FOR THE GRAB HAS
BEEN MOUNTING.
THE MASSES HAVE BEEN DELUDED
ABOUT IT.
MILITARY-STYLE SEMIAUTOMATIC
ASSAULT WEAPONS, OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS JUST A RIFLE.
MASSIVE RISE IN HOMICIDES, BUT
LET'S GO DEEP.
WHAT'S THE MURDER METHOD?
IN A COUNTRY OF OVER 300 MILLION
PEOPLE, 454 MURDER WERE
COMMITTED BY RIFLE.
PUMP ACTION, SOME I GUESS AR-15.
BUT MORE MURDERERS USED THEIR
FISTS AND THEIR FEET.
AND MORE PEOPLE DIED FROM KNIVES
THAN ASSAULT WEAPONS.
AR STAND FOR ARMOR LIGHT RIFLE.
A NAME BRAND.
INNER CITY GANGS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR A BIG CHUNK OF THE BODY
COUNT.
REVOLVERS, GLOKS, EASY TO
CONCEAL.
WHY DOESN'T THE LEFT HARP ON THE
HANDGUNS IF THAT'S THE FIREARM
DOING ALL THE DAMAGE?
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING TO LOOK AT
IN ANOTHER SHOW.
CRAZY CALIFORNIA RELEASED A MAN
WHO TRIED TO ASSASSINATE RONALD
REAGAN.
JOHN HINCKLEY, JR. WAS A FREAK
WHO TRIED TO IMPRESS ACTRESS
JODIE FOSTER.
REAGAN BARELY SURVIVED.
THE WOULD-BE ASSASSIN WAS
PAROLED IN VIRGINIA.
IN LESS THAN A YEAR HE WILL BE
RELEASED FROM ALL COURT
SUPERVISION.
NOBODY MONITORING HIS
IMMEDIATES, TRAVEL OR
COMMUNICATIONS.
SHOOT A PRESIDENT IN THE HEART
AND YEARS LATER YOU ARE A FREE
MAN.
IF YOU QUESTION THE ELECTION OR
THE CDC, I'M SORRY, SIR, YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO COME WITH ME.
AMERICA FEELS LIKE BRUCE WILLIS
IN "12MONKEYS."
YOU ARE VOLUNTEERING.
>> THANK YOU.
JESSE: A $3.5 TRILLION BILL
COSTS NOTHING.
THE BORDER IS SECURE.
AND WHAT'S AFGHANISTAN?
>> WE DID IT TODAY.
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS OF THIS
MISSION WAS DUE TO THE
INCREDIBLE SKILL, BRAVERY AND
SELFLESS COURAGE OF OUR MILITARY
AND DIPLOMATIC OFFICIALS.
JESSE: EVERYTHING COSTS MORE
NOW.
BUT THE GENIUSES IN WASHINGTON
CLAIM IT'S ALL GOING AWAY SOON,
DON'T WORRY.
>> THE DATA SHOWS MOST OF THE
PRICE INCREASES WE HAVE SEEN
WERE EXPECTED TO BE TEMPORARY.
JESSE: NOT SO FAST.
>> DOLLAR TREE IS BREAKING THE
BUCK.
THE STORE WHERE NEARLY
EVERYTHING SELLS FOR $1 IS
RAISING PRICES UP TO 50 CENTS ON
SOME ITEMS TO CORRESPOND THE
COSTS.
JESSE: EVERYTHING IS INFLATED
INCLUDING CNN'S RATINGS.
THE BOTTOM FALLS OUT OF CNN'S
QUARTERLY RATINGS.
NOT A SINGLE CNN PROGRAM
AVERAGED OVER A MILLION VIEWERS.
CNN'S HIGHEST RATED SHOW CUOMO
PRIMETIME CAME IN 23rd PLACE.
TUCKER, THE FIVE, HANNITY, ONE,
TWO, THREE.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE ON TOP OF THE HIDEOUS
BEHAVIOR OF CHRIS CUOMO AND
JEFFREY TOOBIN.
CNN IS DEALING WITH A
CREDIBILITY CRISIS.
CNN HAS BEEN EXPOSED AS A FAKE
NEWS OUTLET THAT TROLLS AND
LIES.
PRACTICALLY NO ONE TUNES INTO
CNN LOL BECAUSE NO ONE TRUSTS
CNN.
CHRIS CUOMO WAS ACCUSED OF
GRABBING A PRODUCER'S BUTT IN
FRONT OF HER HUSBAND.
THE ANCHOR AT CNN INVOLVED IN A
SEX SCANDAL IS NEWS, BUT CNN AND
CORPORATE MEDIA IGNORES IT.
THE NED WORKS DID THE SAME THING
WITH JOHN DURHAM.
NOT A PEOPLE FROM CBS, ABC, NBC
AFTER HILLARY'S CROOKED LAWYER
GOT INDICTED.
BREAKING NEWS ALERTS ANY TIME A
TRUMP ASSOCIATE WAS CHARGED IN
THE WITCH HUNT.
AGAIN, THE PRESS JUST TURNS THE
PHAGE WHEN THE BLOT THICKENS.
THEY JUST SLAPPED CLINTON'S
DIRTY DOSSIER LAW FIRM WITH MORE
SUBPOENAS.
IT IG REPORT FOUND THE FBI
SYSTEMATICALLY LIED AND TRICKED
THE FISA COURT FOR YEARS TO GET
WARRANT TO SPY ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THEY TAIKD EVIDENCE AND THE
MEDIA IS HIDING THE SLEAZE FROM
THE COUNTRY.
JIM COMEY SIGNED OFF ON ALL OF
IT.
BUT THE MOST CORRUPT CHIEF SINCE
HOOVER BASKS IN THE GROVE
LEFT-WING WORSHIP AND A BOOK
DEAL.
THEY ARE THROWING IT IN OUR
FACES.
"POLITICO" JUST CONFIRMED
COMMUNITIER BIDEN'S LAPTOP WAS
LEGIT.
THAT'S HOW YOU RIG A VOTE.
RUN THE OCTOBER SUPPLIES THE
YEAR AFTER THE ELECTION.
THE FAMILY LIED, THE FAMILY WAS
IN BUSINESS WITH CHINESE
COMMUNISTS.
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH FOR A
PROSECUTION.
IN ARIZONA JOE BIDEN BEAT TRUMP
BY 11,000 VOTES.
AN AUDIT FOUND 57,000
QUESTIONABLE BALLOTS JUST IN
THAT ONE COUNTY.
THE MEDIA WASN'T INTERESTED IN
THAT AND ARIZONA OFFICIALS
WOULDN'T FULLY COOPERATE AND
SOME EVIDENCE WAS REMOVED AND
DESTROYED.
THERE IS A DANGEROUS PATTERN IN
THE UNITED STATES.
POLITICIANS, PROSECUTORS AND THE
PRESS ARE ABUSING THEIR POWER TO
WAGE POLITICAL WARFARE AGAINST
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
EVEN WHEN THE ABUSE IS EXPOSED,
THE PRESS RUNS COVER FOR THE
CONSPIRACY.
WE ARE PICKING IT APART.
BUT WE NEED MORE HONEST
AMERICANS ON THE INSIDE.
RUN FOR OFFICE.
BE A REPORTER.
I WOULD TELL YOU TO BE A LAWYER,
BUT THIS COUNTRY DOES NOT NEED
ANY MORE LAWYERS.
SOW GET IT RIGHT OR BE A JUDGE.
WE CAN'T WIN THE BATTL